wealthy
may face up to 61 percent tax rate on
inherited wealth under biden plan that's
a cnbc story
uh sixty-one percent of her resident joe
biden tax plan according to a recent
analysis
as part of his uh american family's plan
biden is proposing to nearly double the
top tax rate on capital gains and
eliminate tax benefits on this
appreciated assets known as the step up
in-base step up in bases
combining the estate tax and a new
higher capital gains rate the repeal
of step up and basis could bring total
effective marginal
tax rates as high as 61
are you kidding me according to an
analysis from the tax foundation the
rate would be the highest
such rate in nearly a century i'll give
this to you and then i'm going to get
a janet yellen update right afterwards
go ahead tell us about this
well it's asinine there's not really
much to talk about
it's not i mean i'm assuming you're
supportive you're really looking forward
to the tax hike to 61
look we are all the great social things
we can do together
all the great programs but i'm all over
philanthropy but you're going to
decimate philanthropy if you do this
that's correct i mean if you think about
the ford
ford's come up three times the ford
foundation and what it's done
in this country and so many other
family legacies that have done things
that the government
wouldn't and shouldn't do shouldn't i
mean there's always a place for
philanthropy but not with that tax rate
it's not and by the way it's like
did i say china i mean they've got to
love things like this
they have to i mean there will be people
who leave
there will be people who get up and
leave the country where are they going
belize costa rica there's a bunch of
places out there that you can live
very nicely i mean you do have to kind
of live off the grid
singapore is at the top you put
singapore there
i mean i mean singapore is definitely a
place for the wealthy to live it's not
hong kong
you think people are actually going to
leave i think that you would have a
handful of people who left i mean think
about
okay september the 9th 1850 california
was admitted into the united states okay
every single year since 1850 the
population of california has grown
dot dot dot until preliminary census
data suggests
2020. there was a 70 000 some odd
net loss of population in the state of
california
you can't tell me that people don't try
and flee
high tax high tax
cities states but what if it's the
country 1850 till 2020 it's grown
it's okay stopped 170 years later 2020.
shout out to gavin newsom oh god
give me back that electoral vote okay
let's take a vote one of you
57 now 56 or something like that it's um
kai how many were did they that's
exactly right if you look at if you look
at california losing a seat that's
exactly right
that's exactly and he's major williams
he needs to use that stat right there
sure major williams needs to use that
stat right there yeah shout out to major
okay speaking of your man crush where
does elon musk hang his hat
austin texas that's true in boca chica
boca raton boca chica there it is
but think about i don't think anyone's
moving to when you said a handful
are you literally saying a handful like
how many people are leaving the country
because of this
genuine question who's going to
singapore some people are going to
puerto rico these days but that's still
part of this country models you can move
some business models you cannot
eduardo true the truth true some people
are moving to puerto rico like
hey pat come to puerto rico be part of
the 420 program pay only four percent
taxes for 20 years
our model doesn't work i wouldn't be
able to go over there anyways but i know
a lot of hedge fund managers who've gone
there
sure i i know and that's all they need
is a computer that's that's the
difference certain jobs you can i pay
taxes in every state i'm appointed in
i'm still paying taxes in california
every every quarter they come they pad
here's to cut the taxes check check
check check check i'm talking
i'm not saying it's the right thing to
do and by the way
it's i mean talk about the midterms i
mean
if they if they try and raise taxes to
this extent
the midterms will be even so you don't
think it's going to go to 61.
you don't think this is going to pass i
i can't see it hap i can't see mansion
letting it happen so so are you familiar
with the reagan tax act uh uh what was
it in 1986
do you know the numbers on what he did
yeah david stockman trickle down
economics
you know actually the numbers what he
did no the numbers would have
but i know he i know the capital gains
change
released release dollars that ran
into both philanthropy and venture
capital as a historical fact
so he brought ordinary income kai helped
me out he brought ordinary income from
50 to 28.
he raised lowest marginal tax rate from
11 to 15 okay and he brought
uh capital gains to 28.
everything was 28 28 and the lowest one
from 11 to 15
is what reagan did and it passed right
and obviously a couple years they did
have some changes to it but he brought
from 50 to 28.
to go to 61 here
i mean this is catastrophic if this
passes
if it passes say it does pass if it
you're talking about people leaving to
another country you know when i hear
this story about people even to another
country it reminds me when democrats
said if trump gets elected i'm moving to
canada
okay look i'm not i'm not saying it's
the right thing to do and i'm not
saying that big names will do it what
the heck
will say some podcasters some engineers
some coders
i'm saying people people who have enough
wealth to care
but they can do their job as you say
anywhere bulking i'm out of here
yeah 60 so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye